Clouds amaze
a tangled thread.
Servers spin
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, David Flanagan,
also known as Rawkode, and this is Rawkode
Live.
Rawkode Live is a show where we take
a look at emerging cloud native technologies, patterns,
architectures, and everything in between to show you
how to be successful.
And today, we're taking a look at a
project that is near and dear to my
heart, and that is Fermion Spin.
If you have met me at a conference
before, you know that I don't think enough
people are paying attention to WebAssembly and server
side Web Assembly.
And today, I'm joined by Thorsten Hans from
the Fermion team to show us what we're
missing out on.
Hello, Thorsten. How are you, man? Hey. Thanks
for having me, David. So first of all,
it's great to be here and talk about
Spin and WebAssembly.
Yeah. I mean, thank you so much for
taking time out of your day. I was
literally just watching you on an hour long
stream on your own channel, and here you
are signing up for another hour long stream
showing people how to do really cool things
with WebAssembly and spend. So I really appreciate
you going back to back today because that
that is no easy task at all.
Yeah. Yeah. You're right. So I just jumped
off the other stream. Right? So I had
a quick bio break for two minutes or
so and then jumped on on Rawkode Academy.
That's yeah. It is what it is. I
mean, it's intense, but we do, you know,
we do it because we love what we
do. Right. It's passion.
And so, you know, passion led us here.
So let's use that momentum and jump right
into spin.
Awesome.
All right. Well, hello to Ravi. Thank you
for saying hello in the chat.
Thurston, before we, you know, start showing people
some cool code and cool technology, can you
just take a moment to tell people a
little bit more about you and what you've
been up there?
Sure. So, yeah, as you already mentioned, my
name is Thorsten.
I'm
based in Germany,
and I work as a senior cloud advocate
with Fermion.
So my daily job, you know,
consists of creating samples,
writing blog posts, engaging with the community,
and also
meeting or sitting down with customers or developer
teams and help them to adopt
WebAssembly
and spin as a technology stack to build
serverless or reactive
application,
but applications,
but also,
you know,
like build the
or integrate spin and maybe
SpinCube as a open source
platform or runtime into their existing
workloads
or
environments. Right? Because,
you know, there are so many
distributed applications
out there and
it's pretty rare that people can just, you
know, wipe everything and start from scratch. Although
that would be great and from time to
time we as developers
have that opportunity, but it's it's seldom. So,
yeah,
job is really to
examine what's there and how could Spin and
WebAssembly
help teams to move forward fast
and to optimize
maybe their cloud
poster to lower
their cloud spendings to run more efficiently.
Bringing
all those
value additions from WebAssembly
into a real world context. That's basically what
I
I do on a on a daily basis.
Yeah.
Awesome. Thank you so much for sharing all
that. Now you mentioned a couple of things
there that I think would be good to
kinda just explain. So you mentioned SpinCube.
We've already mentioned Spin. These were both donated
to the CNCF within the last month. Right?
So these are now official CNCF sandbox
projects.
But I'm assuming some people may not know
what SpendKube is. So maybe we could stay
you know, just take a minute or two
to tell people and fill them in on
that.
Yeah. That's that's a great
maybe opening that discussion,
right?
Yes, so first and foremost,
Spin recently
got accepted
to be a CNCF sandbox project And we
are right now in that onboarding phase, you
know, where things have to have to be
moved around and, you know, we expect us
to, you know, be on that
small tiny CNCF landscape
soon, really soon.
So there there will be a spin logo
there, which is great.
And so spin is in essence is a
developer tool
allowing
developers to build
applications
using WebAssembly.
So
from a developer's point of view, you may
think of WebAssembly as a compilation target,
right? So
we can write code, compile it down to
WebAssembly, and then we leverage a so called
WebAssembly runtime
to execute our workloads.
And in contrast to like,
yeah, earlier like distribution formats, you know, WebAssembly
has some nice
features that we could participate
when building WebAssembly, which is their distributable format
is super tiny because we're just,
you know, sending, let's say, the WebAssembly
module to that whatever runtime
you decide to use in order to run
that app. Right? So in you could think
of a WebAssembly
distributable
or size wise, it relates to a container
as a container relates to a virtual machine.
Right? So it's maybe a hundred times smaller
than a container. That's one of the, big
benefits because pull times, especially in Kubernetes,
are like ridiculously
fast. Right?
And we have, you know,
strict isolation,
strict sandboxing.
So so the workloads are secure so you
can run
multi tenant run times and don't have to
fear one workload taking down another one.
But yes, so Spin is the tool
to,
simplify the development process. And it doesn't matter
if you're a TypeScript person, a JavaScript person,
a Python, a Go, a Rust person person,
right?
Spin is like a unified CLI giving you
a super simple
CLI workflow. And we will look at that,
right, by doing some hands on in a
in a few minutes.
So the Spin takes care of all those
developer day to day tasks
for you.
And then we mentioned SpinCube like two times
right now.
So SpinCube
is also an open source project. It's a
sub project under the spin project.
It's also
as part of our contribution
to CNCF.
It's also in CNCF as sent on the
sandbox layer.
And that's basically a way of running those
spin apps
in Kubernetes
without
leveraging containers
because,
you know, we wanna take or we wanna
make use of those values like small binary
size,
incredibly
fast
instantiation
and runtime performance.
So SpinTube,
again, to emphasize that is also open source,
is also part of the spin project, which
means it's part of the CNCF sandbox
tier
and
could be installed to like, any arbitrary
Kubernetes cluster.
And it's a I think as a final
statement to spin queue before looking at it,
I think it's a perfect example of how
versatile
WebAssembly run times could be. Right? There could
be like a way,
oh, SpinCube is the way of running it
in Kubernetes,
mimicking like ports and all those primitives that
we know and love from Kubernetes.
But maybe you're more onto,
I wanna just build a workload,
throw it over the wall and get it
executed somewhere.
That's for example, where a different runtime,
which is firming cloud hosted service
that we provide
enters the stage. That's just a different way
of how those WebAssembly modules are executed,
are managed
under
on that platform there.
Awesome.
Yeah. Great explanations. Thank you so much for
sharing that. We understand spin. We understand spin
queue. I'll add one little bonus nugget there,
and it is that, you know, I get
to sit and play with a lot of
technology.
Like, every day, I just I'm like a
technology magpie. Right? And if it's shiny, I
play with it. And I've gotta say, for
anyone watching this video, pay attention to the
developer experience as source them as part of
the first stuff. Because I really believe that
spend have just absolutely nailed it. The the
way that you build components and add components
and
iterate of building a real application. I I
I just think it's unmatched. I hope people
enjoy that and appreciate that as you're hacking
on your demo.
Now, with that being said,
what are we building today?
Well,
so, yeah, obviously, David and I were chatting
in advance of that stream a little bit
about how could we, you know,
provide most value for, like,
newcomers that have never experienced WebAssembly,
never experienced Spin,
and for those who may have already used
Spin.
So the idea is to start with a
Hello World to give you like, you know,
to make
the audience avail or
aware of like those the Spin workflow.
And from there, we start like implementing,
for example, an HTTP API.
And last but not least, there could be
no session without some AI. Right? So we
will bring in some AI capabilities
as well.
Just to give you a rough idea of
how
would I maybe integrate an upstream service that
I have already in my
environment
that I wanna use from within Spin.
So that's the idea.
Awesome.
Alright. I got a comment from Indigo VFX
saying that my volume is very low compared
to yours. So, hopefully, I fixed that. If
not, I will keep on tweaking. So please
let me know, Indigo.
Thorsten.
I I turned myself up, Thorsten. I I
think it's me that's the problem. It's always
me that's the problem.
Do you want to share your screen? We'll
move over there, and we'll start
having some fun that was spent.
Yes.
So I
now you should see my screen.
We do indeed. I see you. I see
the Fermion developer homepage. I am excited and
happy to let you take stage.
Awesome.
So let's get rid of the
notification from Chrome over here and let's
close that tab. And yeah, as you already
mentioned, we are looking at the Fermion Developer
Home
because I think that's a good like resource
to get started depending
on
whatever the preferred language is that you wanna
use to build WebAssembly
workloads or spin apps, how we call them.
So we have documentation
in place for Spin
guiding you through, okay, what is Spin?
How to install it on different operating systems?
And then we have language guides.
Right? Because there is like,
you know, there are so many languages that
you can use to build WebAssembly workloads.
We
have detailed information on, for example,
how I wanna use rust, right, for example.
So what do I have to install?
So you need rust, you need a
given target, the wasn't 32 was a p
one target. So there's documentation for like our
main languages,
but also for other languages that are that
you could take as of today and compile
down to WebAssembly.
But I think we should not spend time
on,
you know, telling people how to install Node.
Js in our example, because I think that's
a problem already solved out
solved and
we should
get started
by
taking Spin for a spin.
So I'm on
macOS and I'm a Homebrew user. So I
installed Spin
using Homebrew.
However, there's also install script that you can
just curl and execute on your machine
that works across
Linux, different Linux distributions
that works on Mac OS as well. And
obviously for Windows,
we provide binaries that you can download and
use on a on a Windows machine.
I haven't used Windows,
to be honest, in the last
ten years or so.
Looked into quite good these days. I mean
Yeah, it is. You know, I always struggle
with what I refer to as the device
romance.
That's like having like
a brick like my MacBook Pro with Windows.
Okay. Maybe
that could be an option that I could
could look into. But yeah, I'm always lacking
like those those those nice
capabilities
provided by Apple Silicon and their battery life.
Anyways, we're not here. So I run NextOS.
So for everyone else who's in that Next
ecosystem, there is a Next package for spin,
and it works great.
Unlike you Awesome. On your Apple device, I
get about three hours battery on my laptop
because it's Linux and x 86. So what
can you do?
Yeah. That's I think yeah. We could go
deep on recommending
different
recommending
different hardware
and operating systems.
But I think the
most important
takeaway over here is that Spin is available
for all those popular operating systems, for all
the
architectures
on those operating systems that
people ask for. Right? So for Windows, there's
an x
64 build for macOS. Obviously, have Intel ARM
builds for Linux. We have Intel ARM builds.
Yeah. So
choose your poison and then install Spin
using your preferred
way.
I know a few people that use Brew
on Linux, although that felt alien to me,
but that works as well.
Awesome.
Okay. So I obviously
have installed
Spin. Let me bump the font size. I
think this should work.
Yeah. I mean, that looks okay for me.
If anyone has any issues reading that, please
let us know in the comments and we
will increase it some more. But I think
it looks good, man. All good. Okay. Cool.
So I have installed Spin on my machine.
Let me quickly do a Witch,
Spin over here.
We also have a version manager for spin,
but I wouldn't go that deep into detail
of the different plugins that I'm running right
now.
I think most important takeaway is I have
a spin executable in my path
and I can use spin version to determine,
hey, I'm on a on a recent version
of Spin.
And I have installed NVM
as my
node manager. And right now I switched to
node 22. So I think that's the latest
LTS or the most recent LTS version.
So
the idea is to start from scratch, build
a hello world in the first place. So
the spin workflow is I have my language
specific tooling installed.
We're right now wearing the hat of a
JavaScriptTypeScript
developer,
right? So I
stumbled upon that spin new command in
the spin docs, curious about that. I execute
it
and I get asked by the CLI, hey,
just pick a template to start your application.
Right? So there we provide different templates. You
can roll your own. The community already created
several
templates that you can just install from a
git endpoint or so.
And
let's say we wanna roll with TypeScript
for the sake of this example.
So I choose the template. I provide a
name for my app. And as I promised,
we do a hello world
over here. We skip the description
for now.
And as I as I've chosen HTTP
TS,
so before the hyphen, there's the the kind
of trigger. So what will actually make my
workload run?
And it is obviously incoming HTTP requests in
that in the case of HTTP
dash.
So I have to tell
Spin
on which routes it should invoke
my WebAssembly application.
So forward slash and three dot basically
means
everything
starting from the root route and all its
children routes
below that.
But we could be more precise. We could,
for example, say I'm building an API
and I just want to respond to incoming
calls on my listener that is like a
port
or
a custom domain name,
followed by a forward slash,
followed by the API prefix and then everything
underneath that.
But
let's stick with the defaults for now.
Okay.
So what we got right now is we
got a new hello world folder. If we
move into that one
and explore that for a second, we see
a lot of familiar
file names
from
a typical TypeScript project. Right? We see a
package JSON like in every JavaScript project. We
see a TSConfig JSON, a Webpack config. So
it should look pretty familiar
for a JavaScript slash TypeScript developer
because we wanna align or our intention is
to align with the idioms
that are like,
you know, set in stone for whatever language
you choose. Right? Are there any plans to
support
you know, obviously, this is using node 22.
We've got the TS config. We see Webpack's
being used for the, you know, the bundling
aspect of it. Are there any plans to
support something like Deno or Bard an alternative
TypeScript runtimes in the Or is it kind
of tied to Webpack for the time being?
So
regarding bundling or packaging like those modules, we
I think there is no plan on replacing
Webpack right now.
Regarding the underlying runtime,
so
with
I think couple of months ago, we released
version three dot o of the Spin SDK
for JavaScript.
That relies on a runtime called StarlingMonkey.
So StarlingMonkey
is
like is a JavaScript runtime maintained by the
bytecode lines
that we package together with your application source
code
into the web web assembly binary
that you distribute
across
like boundaries across, you know, maybe you upload
it to Firmware Cloud.
So your app is fully functioning
and you don't need any kind of JavaScript
runtime on
this server or this serverless platform, right on
the on the target,
so to say.
So regarding runtimes,
we recently switched to StarlingMonkey
regarding bundling and tooling in the JavaScript
templates.
That's what we currently have.
I would love to, you know, chat about
what's the current state. Is Webpack still the
cool kit? Or
is everything is everyone moving away from that?
I will be super happy to to get
feedback on that one and to bring in
like a simple
variable.
Right? Those templates can ask questions.
So by default, we right now use NPM
as a package manager.
I've already created a PR to bring in
YARN and p and the other one p
n
p n, I guess, if I remember correct.
Yeah.
P n p m is still
We still have to file a PR for
that one. But yeah, we are continuously
improving those templates to meet the community where
it is.
All right. Thank you.
So there's one addition.
Oh, sorry, did I interrupt you?
No, no, no, you didn't. I was just
saying thank you. Okay.
Now I thought you were just taking
a break to ask another question. But anyways.
So this is,
as I said, should look familiar for JavaScript
or Node developers
with one exception that being spin dot toml.
So if we open up the folder in
in code,
for example,
to browser
to, you know, move around in those files.
So the spin toml, that's the application manifest
where all the things are pulled together.
So we have some fundamental
information about the application.
We have, okay,
configuration for the trigger. So what is basically
responsible for making my my app
run.
Right? That's incoming HTTP requests on all and
on all routes.
If we receive such an HTTP request, we
wanna invoke
the hello world component.
And for components, we always have two configuration
tables.
One is the
component
configuration
where we specify,
okay,
the wasm module is here and
please exclude the following files.
And we have build instructions.
Because
if you think about, you know, building more
complex systems with spin and maybe use Python
for one where Python makes most sense.
You use Rust for something where you wanna
get wanna have best performance
and you wanna use TypeScript for a different
component where you
wanna meet the developer or where your I
don't know, your teammates
are most confident in writing TypeScript. So you
may end up with a mixture
of languages.
However, we think
that the DX, the developer experience should be
consistent across those languages.
So spin
gives you a spin build command. Under the
covers, we execute whatever's mentioned over here for
this particular component.
We also have like a spin watch command
so that you can while you code behind
the scenes, the app gets recompiled
and you have like those hot reload capabilities.
So
whenever
you execute a spin watch, whatever is mentioned
in line 19 will be executed for the
sake of this component.
So basically, it's that, you know,
translating an agnostic workflow into a language specific
workflow.
That's basically what we have over here.
I think the component configuration is something we
will revisit for a more realistic
demo in a few minutes.
But for now, think of it as fundamental
or basic component
configuration.
So that's really the only special thing in
a spin application
is the spin
TOML file.
We have a source folder with an index
TS and we decided
to
provide or to use or to add IDRouter,
which is like a popular router in a
in a known ecosystem
that's not tied or tightly coupled to a
framework. We just wanna have a router over
here.
However, you could also use Hono, I think
is the other popular router in an old
world
to
create routing capabilities.
So this is basically the hello world example.
Right? So we register to get routes or
API will only respond to incoming get requests
at root route or at hello.
And as,
you know, you may already guess, there is
a route parameter called name.
So it does not matter if I if
I send a get request to hello David
or to hello slash torsten.
We expect that to be returned via HTTP.
So like a personalized greeting API
or personalized
hello world.
So let's do
some housekeeping
over here. We have some squiggly lines because
I haven't,
but because I did not run NPM install
so far. And we think that something that
should happen automatically.
So let me move back to the terminal
pretty quickly.
I'm in the hello world folder
again. So this is where SpinToma resists and
I'd simply do a spin build.
So right now it's double checking, oh, Torsten
decided
to use TypeScript and the build instruction
tells the tooling,
hey, run an NPM install.
That takes a while right now.
For that.
It's pulling down the dependencies.
And right now
it's executing the build instruction.
So there is a build command and let
me go back into
package JSON. So there is, you know, we
use some tooling that we created and again,
upstream tooling from the bytecode alliance
to take your
JavaScript source code that could just, you know,
be one file that could be like a
regular project layout. It doesn't matter.
And turn that into
a WebAssembly module.
So we end up by executing that spin
build
with a hello world dot wasm file.
If we now look at lsla
dist was the subfolder,
we can see, oh, let's add an h
over there. So that's 12 megabytes in size
for Hello World.
But
it's not just our application code. It's also
the
JavaScript runtime that I mentioned earlier. Starling Monkey
is part of this distributable.
Right?
So how does that work? Behind the scenes,
we take
and I think that's super
that's nothing, you know, people have to be
aware of when building their first applications.
But to me as a developer, I think
this is super
that's just awesome technology what happens on the
covers. Right? We have this as the user
code or we often refer to as the
guest code. So that will become the WebAssembly
module.
So we take
your,
that code.
We take that StarlingMonkey
JavaScript engine.
So we start that engine during the build.
We load the user code that loads, you
know, a
vast amount of node JS dependencies
the entire tree depending on what we import
and evaluate
the global scope.
And once we have evaluated
the global scope,
we take a memory snapshot
from that and write that to disk.
Meaning for every invocation of our app,
there is no bootstrapping
of the JavaScript runtime because it was bootstrapped.
The dependencies are evaluated.
The global scope of my custom code, of
my guest code is evaluated,
and the app is ready to
handle the request,
resulting in JavaScript
code compiled down to WebAssembly having a better
cold start performance than JavaScript code.
And that's just, you know, when I stumbled,
when I, you know, discovered all those internals
and what happens during build time for
interpreter or interpreter languages like JavaScript, Python, that's
just, yeah,
kind of mind blowing. It's super awesome to
see how far
we could push technology to optimize
for perf for performance.
That's pretty cool.
Okay. So we build we executed spin build,
tossed and got sidetracked, talked about all the
internals.
Sorry for that.
But now let's close the loop.
So we have spin up, which basically
takes your WebAssembly module
and starts a listener on your local machine
to, you know, serve as an inner loop
as a, you know, development
time
web server
and every invocation.
So for every time I will move to
the second to a new terminal instance over
here and I will do a curl
local local
local host
3,000.
Right?
And we get a hello universe and right
now let's say hello
David over there, we get a hello David.
So for every request
I sent
to localhost 3,000,
a cold start happens under the cover. So
every time the WebAssembly module is loaded,
first time it's loaded from disk, second time
it could be loaded from within,
you know, the the heap because we know
it was already there. Chances are high that
it will be requested again.
And then a clean instance is executed.
So there's no shared state. Right? Every invocation
is a cold start.
And
the the
amazing,
like, performance we can get out of that
is, for example, I think number of requests
is this
and this is concurrent threads.
And let's call yeah. Let's just invoke hello
universe over there with 100 concurrent threads 10
k.
So we are able to
I think we are we logging? No, we
are not logging. So we are able to
where's the histogram? A distribution there is 99%
of the request in less than o dot
o five six seconds
and
you know without,
putting pressure
on my machine at all because
those modules are so tiny
in size and could be
instantiated
and invoked
so fast.
So this is a pretty bare bones hello
world. Right?
Like
find new
TypeScript,
http TypeScript in this case, doing a spin
build, doing a spin up,
and then I can run it on my
local machine.
Or if you wanna deploy it to, for
example,
Fermion Cloud, we have Spin Cloud,
help.
So
everyone could register for free and run five
apps for free over there.
Or you may
wanna leverage
SpinCube.
Let me quickly bring up the website for
This is again open source. You can deploy
that to your Kubernetes cluster.
So we have, you know, documentation on how
to install it with Helm, how to roll
it on Rancher Desktop on different like
Kubernetes
distributions,
so to say.
And
I think we shouldn't go down that path
of setting up SpinCube right now.
From a developer's perspective,
at some point we have to hand over
with operations
people or DevOps
teams.
Right? And we think as a developer,
there
should be like,
oh, we are responsible
to a certain degree of
for getting the app into an environment.
And in our cases, obviously we have to
somehow share the app.
So instead of reinventing the wheel, we decided,
hey, you we integrate with
TTL,
SH for example. We integrate with what's out
there which OCI.
So you can
simply
ask Spin to
create an OCI artifact
and
distribute that through registries
like Docker Hub or like Azure Container Registry
or TTLSH
which is like an anonymous
and ephemeral
registry that I use for demonstration purposes.
Right? So this right now takes the WASM
file and the SpinTML,
package that together
and uploads that as an old OCI artifact,
meaning that the Kubernetes cluster
with SpinCube
can pull that and run it.
So the overall end end to end, the
OCI artifact
will be 12 megabytes
in size plus
those 404
bytes for the SpinTML file.
And
yes, to be honest, JavaScript
due to the runtime and Python
are the biggest distributable.
So Rust, Go, those are obviously tinier in
size
because we don't have to ship an entire
runtime as part of the application.
So for Rust, with all optimizations,
we could go down to two digit kilobytes
in size for the distributable.
Okay. So
speaking about developers
responsibilities.
So we shared our app right now and
it is available under this tag, right? So
if people are following along right now, they
can do a spin
up dash dash from
pass in
that,
what is it, tag? No, no, repository
or the ref the OCI reference.
And then your spin CLI
goes, pulls that OCI artifact and spawns it
from that OCI artifact.
So how do we get into a platform
like Kubernetes?
So we think we should not reinvent that
wheel, however, provide a great developer experience.
So we that we say spin cube scaffold
from
t t l s h and without me
adding more flags to that command,
I get
a Kubernetes deployment manifest. So that may look
familiar for those viewers of,
or for you David as I know you
have like a like a whole lot of
Kubernetes experience.
So you could already guess some things from
this
this YAML.
There is a CRD that will be deployed
as part of
SpinCube
to your Kubernetes cluster.
We have a concept of a SpinApp executor.
So we are using a container, the shim
implementation
under the covers
to run those WebAssembly workloads
instead of running containers.
And we want to horizontally scale this to
have two replicas.
And we think
our story with deploying Spin apps into Kubernetes
should end here
and integrate seamlessly
what you're used to use.
Maybe you wanna or let me simply
switch to a Kubernetes cluster.
So maybe you're cool with kubectl
into
into your cluster.
Right? If you're cool with that, you can
oh, no. Apply.
I was missing apply. Oh, come on.
If you're cool with that, you can do
it. Right? If you wanna use GitOps,
cool. You can GitOps this
manifest
obviously.
If you wanna build a Helm chart around
it,
go for it. Right?
We think we should meet the developers where
they are or in that case, the integration,
the DevOps teams where they are and don't
try to come up with fancy ways of
bringing stuff into Kubernetes.
Can you run a command for me, please?
Sure.
Kubectl
explain
spinapp.spec.
Oh, yeah. You've already run before.
Yep. Yep. Yep. That's yep. That's That's how
much we can interact and and and play
with scheduling,
you know, the spin workload on Kubernetes. But
that that looks pretty comprehensive. That's that's pretty
cool.
Yeah. So we have
so with SpinCube,
what
so leverage
kWASM,
which is another open source project under the
SpinCube organization
that's basically deploying that containerd shim for spin
to the Kubernetes nodes.
And then we use
a SpinAppExecutor.
Right? I we saw that over here, Executor.
And a SpinAppExecutor
is basically another CRD
oh, let's let's go to get SpinAppExecutor.
So
I have my default,
and the SpinCube documentation guides you through that.
Right? And it's basically using
the runtime class concepts of Kubernetes telling
telling the scheduler, hey, instead of scheduling a
container workload,
schedule
a workload that's using the WasmTime
Spin v two runtime under the covers. So
it's loosely coupled
and allows you to,
yeah, to run SpinApps in Kubernetes. So we
can get a k get
SpinApp.
So you see
a couple of spin apps deployed there. One
is scaled to 20.
And
for every spin app in SpinCube, you get
a port. All ports are running.
And the nice thing about
let me k edit
spin app.
What is it? Hello spin.
So this is scaled to 20 replicas right
now.
Let's go there and scale it into two.
So this is manually scaling. Right? We integrate
with KEDA, HPA,
blah blah blah, you name it. Yeah. So
so we should be down
to way less ports.
And
the value of small binary
and ridiculously
fast
instantiation and invocation
is
gets visible when I do the when I
inverse it again. So if I do a
spin app, edit spin app again,
go over here and say, wanna have 20.
I save it, I do k get p
o
and there we are.
Within a fraction of a second they are
all up and running because
nothing happens. Right? The image gets pulled
and the manifest gets obviously interpreted.
Right? And things are checked
and the listener is already there.
Right? So we spawn a subprocess on the
note,
but the app is every invocation is a
cold start.
Right? So within a matter of seconds, we
are up and running with like 20 instances.
Yeah. So we consider the the scale that
we use for these pods as it's really
it it's a web server. Like, we just
it's like a proxy. I know it's not
technically,
but the requests are coming in, and then
it's CGI
CGI ing out to the spin application.
So that might help make sense for how
do we know when to run one of
these polytorsies 20. And it's if we just
pretend on our head, again, even though it's
not, that it's NGINX,
that might help make it easier for people
to understand.
We also have a few questions in the
Sure. The comment section if you're happy to
answer those. So Indigo VFX is asking,
is there a performance difference between the various
workload languages? So if I write something in
HTTP Rust versus HTTP JSON,
even though the WASM binaries are different sizes,
is there a runtime performance?
Yeah. So definitely,
definitely Rust is by far the
fastest
or resulting in the fastest
binary or application.
Right? Because
although we,
let's say, warmed up the JavaScript runtime, we
loaded
the dependencies, we evaluated
the global scope,
there is still the like
run time overhead
that's introduced by using a interpreted language like
JavaScript.
So
Rust,
Golang,
like non interpreted languages will always be faster.
Also because
distributable size is smaller and at some point
especially
with
when using Kubernetes
from cloud vendors,
disk IO
becomes also a problem because loading a 12
megabyte WASM file from disk is slower than
loading a 30 kilobyte or
hundred kilobyte
WASM file from disk.
So yes, there is a performance
difference
and we always treat it that way. If
you are looking for best performance,
go the Rust way.
If you're looking for a convenient developer
experience
and easy to adopt
like
SDKs
and stuff like that than TypeScript.
Maybe the smarter choice
and Go is the nice thing sitting exactly
in the middle giving you better performance but
still having a
a language that one could learn in like
a couple of days at least to get
going,
which is slightly different for Rust, if you
ask me.
No shit.
Alright.
Thank you for answering that question. I hope
that helps Indigo.
Ravi also has a question and is curious
if spend supports open telemetry.
So
Test off. We'd instrument
ourselves within the spend application,
or is this something that the SpinKube runtime
handles for us? Maybe you could shed some
light there. Yeah. That's that's a great question,
Ravi. Thanks for bringing that up.
So
Spin does automatic
telemetry
or Spin produces
telemetry.
And we integrate
seamlessly
with open telemetry
stacks
like for example, we have a plugin
that you could spin
auto
setup for example with Aspire
or with the default stack is I think
Jager Prometheus
or you know all the entire you know
the entire tool chain that
that's used to
to build the OTEL stack.
I like Aspire because it's like that single
container developer in a loop stack.
So
if I do a spin
OTEL
up,
I think,
and let me curl the app again
10,000
times and right now do a spin hotel
open aspire.
So we should see
automatic telemetry
automatically being populated.
Our app does nothing right now, so that's
why we only have two spans per invocation.
But we
add,
you know, interesting boundaries. So for example, if
you call a kv store, what we create
obviously
spends and correlate them up into that graph.
We provide fundamental metrics,
but that needs a couple of minutes to
be picked
up by Aspire.
So we will see like invocation count being
being
populated there in a few seconds.
And obviously, we also get
if we lock to console. Ly what we
don't do in Hello World right now, we
will see structured log output over there.
For
guest logging or guest telemetry, so basically you
as a developer creating your own traces and
spans.
A colleague of mine, so Caleb, will do
a talk next week at WASM.io,
1 of the biggest like WebAssembly conferences in
Europe. And I think that should be up
on YouTube in shortly
after the conference
because there are some
in WebAssembly world, is
WASI, the WebAssembly system interface. So there's a
lot of standardization
work happening
to ensure that you can build a spin
app with spin and run it on a
different runtime.
So
and the same thing is
in Wazi,
there is there
there are efforts to say, hey, across the
board,
these are the APIs
how
guest code
should do traces or should do metric populate
metrics.
And Caleb is somewhat leading in or in
the group of leaders when it comes to
how
OpenTelemetry
should or could work in Wasm.
And so I think that one is definitely
worth checking out.
For now,
you can, if you, for example, in JavaScript
do a console a log that becomes a
log that is, you know, sent to standard
out or standard error if you log to
that one and that those are sent to
the corresponding
log streams there.
But
we don't have support for
traces
or custom spans or metrics
besides
using
maybe Ravi if you have experience with Prometheus,
you can obviously use the push gateway, right,
to push metrics into your Prometheus.
That's definitely possible.
But we are,
you know,
moving forward and trying to come up with
a API that's that works across all the
different languages,
that's easy to understand and that allows developers
to generate all sorts of telemetry data.
Yep.
I hadn't seen that Aspire workflow before, but
that was that was pretty slick. So I
was really happy to see that and and
looking forward.
Now to Caleb's talk on how we do
guest and custom spans because that would be
very, very cool also.
So I hope that answers your question, Ravi.
Yeah. That's I think that's the next logical
step. And
for
for SpinCube,
you can obviously
I think there's a flag somewhere
that you can say, hotel
collect hotel collector exactly.
And you say, hey, there's my hotel collector.
And then the SpinCube runtime will forward all
those telemetry data to that.
Cool. So
next,
we created a Hello World. I think we
could take it one step further
with the JavaScript
API.
Also,
because I think,
David, you mentioned that you are you think
the SpinDX is great.
And I think we could,
you know, demonstrate a little more of the
SpinDX
to
make people aware of
that great developer experience.
So
let's do, this is super unscripted.
Let's do a spin you.
And
I think it's I always
try to get a sense of the community.
And by having a community that engages and
ask questions and is curious about perf and
stuff like that.
That gives me like the confidence. Okay. I
could bring in some more details and share
maybe some
not get best. I hate the term best
practices,
but let's say good practices.
So
I find it super valuable to have an
HTTP empty template. And let's say this is
crud.
The HTTP empty template is basically just splitting
out a spin TOML
with almost no content. So no trigger, no
component, nothing.
Because maybe you wanna build something that consists
of more than just
a single component.
And then the HTTP empty template is what
you what you're looking for. It's like
if people have experience
with Microsoft
or .net or in Visual Studio,
this is like a solution.
And now we are adding projects or different
workloads to our solution.
So we can simply say spin
at over here and let's say again, let's
start with TypeScript and let's say this is
my API
and I wanted that to respond to incoming
calls
underneath API.
So if we look at spin. Toml right
now,
we see, hey, right now we have a
trigger
and we have
build commands,
component configuration,
but all is pointing to work here.
So the folder structure oops. The folder structure
has right now an API subfolder. Right? So
we can organize different
workloads and subfolders
to to, you know, work seamlessly with mono
repo,
organize or mono repos or, you know, to
organize things in a more meaningful way.
So we may add
a front end for example. So how could
we do that?
We have
the static file server,
which is basically a web assembly module we
created
that's able to serve files from a predefined
folder and return them over HTTP.
So this is like a let's call it
a recipe, right? For
I have an idea, I wanna build an
app that app uses maybe Vue. Js, Angular,
React, whatever to build a for building a
SPA, a single page application.
And I wanna have an API
next to it so that the front end
can immediately talk to the API. So static
file servers what we are looking for, we
call this thing
front end.
And we say we wanna serve that on
the root of our
port
and we wanna have
all the files for the front end resist
in the front end folder. And now we
have a nice
structure again, let's open Oh, let's maybe do
this one and let's open
code in front end
and let's implement our single page application
and
at the beginning that should be as easy
as this.
So this is our front end, Right? It's
more about
orchestrating
the things and running them instead of me
implementing a single page application
because that will look not that great. I'm
not a UX guy. I'm not a CSS
guy.
Yeah. So bear with me.
But that's
Why is the close button not working? I
don't know.
So that's that's Let's say that's our front
end. Right? So we have
two folders, but still the workflow is the
same. We do a spin build. It iterates
over all our components. It checks, do we
have build instructions for that?
If so, I execute that for the API.
It's again doing an
NPM installing
all the dependencies.
That's what takes a second right now.
Then it's compiling the API down to WebAssembly.
Then it checks for the front end. I
don't have to do any build steps. So
I'm done.
If I do a spin up right now,
and I can see I have two available
routes. So I can immediately browse low close
3,000
and get back my
my document. Okay. Maybe it's worth
adding a little more content to our HTML
page. Right? But it is my
HTML I created a second ago.
And I have
a listener right on
the API
which returns
with a four zero four by default.
So now we can maybe spend a couple
of minutes in laying out a simple API
that's more than just
to get endpoints over here. Right?
It gave me a four zero four although
there is a root route registered.
But when adding the component,
I said it should listen to API
forward slash.
So I have to mimic that obviously over
here.
So this would make the app respond to
my port my assigned port forward slash API
and so on and so forth.
So
I said there are some more nuggets in
SpinCLI.
So for example,
we are so far we only talked about
the trigger, right? About things that,
you know, make our app run. But somehow
we have to store data, retrieve data,
and Spin has an SDK
for TypeScript,
for for Rust,
for Go, for Python,
that simplifies
things like that. So for example, let's say
we want to build an app to retrieve
to retrieve
values
and
want to retrieve values by a certain
value by key
and also we have a
post API to set a value. Let's get
rid of that. And that's what we basically
handle
set
and we will implement that handle
get by
key
and this is
handle
get all. Right. So that's what we're going
to implement.
So,
you know, you recognize there's a colon followed
by key, that's a route parameter.
So we can pull that
by saying, I'm not interested in the request.
So this gives me basically access to the
first argument gives me access to the incoming
request object.
And the second one allows me to pull
data,
for example, from the route parameters,
the key in that case.
So let me
come up with that. So right now TypeScript
TypeScript
compiler transpiler would
yell at me that I'm not using request.
So I can simply say
underscore to ignore it and pass in the
key into my handler.
And for this one, we will update that
one in a second because we wanna use
the request payload.
Right? Because user should send a post request
with JSON.
The the payload contains the value
and the key is part of the URL
and then we store that in key value
stores. Let me quickly create the stops for
those functions.
So let's say const,
I like that style of defining
JavaScript functions or TypeScript functions in that case.
Okay.
So this
and
this.
So here we get a key which is
a string.
Over there, we get the key which is
a string. But in addition to the key,
we wanna use
the request payload.
So let's let's call it the body and
that's of type array buffer.
And to get the array buffer,
that's a stream.
We can read the stream and we wanna
do that async.
So we can say
await
request
array buffer.
And now it's almost we are almost in
good shape, but we don't return anything back.
So let's make it happy over there by
saying return status
for now. So
this is basically
reminding me to implement it.
Okay. So this is the shape of the
API. So now the question is how?
How can we leverage like a data storage?
Right? And
with the Spin SDK,
give you like
super simple yet
valuable APIs
to achieve day to day tasks.
And one of them is, for example, using
key value stores.
So
WebAssembly
has a capability or strict sandbox, a capability
based security
model.
And by default,
your code is not allowed to use anything.
It's not allowed to do outbound HTTP.
It's not allowed to read environment
variables.
It's not allowed to do outbound TCP and
talk to key value store. So you have
to explicitly grant the permission. And this is
like, although it might sound
super tedious in the first place,
but it's giving you the confidence that your
code is only doing what you wanted it
to do.
And also for the teams
or for the people that run a platform
that runs workloads like that, they have the
confidence
that
no matter what the user code does, it
aligns with all the capabilities
that are specified in its manifest.
So that's one of the if you ask
me, that's one of the greatest
values
provided by WebAssembly.
Okay. So how do we do that? How
do we give our app access to Kivelli
store?
So again, in Spin, we try to simplify
that as much as possible.
So we open up the folder where our
spin toml resists
and we have that component configuration over here.
So allowed outbound host
is the property that you can use to,
for example, allow my API
to send requests to httpsapi.github.com.
Right? Without this being explicitly mentioned here,
outgoing
fetch
calls or HTTP requests to that origin
will fail.
And the same applies to key
value
stores and SQL lite databases
and so on and so forth. So there
are like they are all documented obviously.
So I wanna give
my app access to a named key value
store called default.
You can use different name,
but then you have to provide configuration
like connection string, where that resists.
But default is like a super convenient way
of doing that
because
if we do a spin
where are we? We are there. If we
do a spin build again,
it should still build everything as we saw
before.
Okay.
If we do a spin up right now,
you can see storing default key value data
to dot spin key value DB.
So the CLI
knows, hey, Torsten wants to use a key
value store,
instead of he
us asking him to run a key value
store in a container or something like that,
let's simply roll a SQLite
database for him that acts as a key
value store.
Right? If that if that's cool for me,
I can use that. If I wanna leverage
Redis that's out there in my cluster, I
just have to provide a configuration
aside or besides my app
and tell the Spin app to use a
runtime so called configuration
file. So I don't have to change my
code
to point to Redis instead of
the developer
key value store.
Alright.
This
is the SpinTML.
This is our implementation.
How could I right now
retrieve all the keys from the Key Value
Store?
So this is where we can use
the key the the Spin
SDK.
So there is a Spin SDK. Why is
that not okay.
Let's use KV and
then we can either open a named key
value store or we can say, I wanna
leverage the default key value store. So right,
on my machine default is right now using
SQLite.
I can override that and can say default
right now points to Redis. So it's just
a name to loosely couple
the application implementation
from its configuration.
And key value has
or exposes
like simple APIs.
So for example, get keys.
I can simply call that.
That gives me all keys.
And then I can say
const values
equals
all keys.
Let's say, now we can use a map,
so there's a key
and we take that key and then we
return
key being key and value being
k v get,
let's say get
JSON, no get JSON, that's like this.
That was rust. Sorry for that.
And then we return
like whatever is there in values
and instead of returning an HTTP 500,
we simply use the JSON helper from the
ET router to return
the entire contents
of our key value store.
Right? So again,
and I think this is super important. The
idea is from the Spin SDK to provide
simple
yet useful APIs
to speed up your developer,
performance when building,
applications for the cloud or for a serverless
platform.
Cool.
Let's quickly implement the other two's because that's
super easy.
We ah, maybe interesting thing, there could be
network in between our spin app and the
key value store. Right?
So
if something fails, if a error is thrown
and it's not caught by your guest code,
spin catches the error
and returns an h t p 500.
Right? So that's obviously that's that is and
should be used. You should use try catch
to catch errors and you know, handle them
with care and handle them correctly.
But in the worst case, the surrounding or
the underlying runtime catch the error and returns
an http 500.
Alright.
If the key is faulty,
meaning if it's empty, undefined, null, we return
a new response
and saying this is
a bad request
and setting the status to 400.
Okay.
Otherwise,
we say, hey, if
not KV exists
at position key,
we return,
let's copy that.
Nope, let's copy that and say, this is
a four zero four
not found.
And if it exists, we return
JSON
kv
get JSON
at key
and are done with implementing
the handle get by key.
Last but not least, they're set.
So we expect our code
to
provide a payload
once JSON
parse.
So this is a new int eight array
and we have to turn that into a
string. We can use a decoder,
new text decoder by default UTF eight which
is the right one. So we can say
decode
body.
So we end up with something turned
into an object by using JSON parse. This
could fail, right?
Error.
So we could again return
bad request.
Or let's do it like this.
No, no, let's do it, let's do it
like this.
Okay, so if
we get a payload, let's say if,
let's accept any payload for now. And let's
say, const kv equals
kv open default
and let's say kv
set at key,
our set JSON JSON.
At position key, we wanna set the entire
payload. So whatever the user sends over the
wire, this is not a good API, right?
Because we accept everything
from the user. So we have at least
we should at least do some housekeeping over
there.
Maybe if key
if not key return
new response
that
that request
status
400.
Maybe let's move that over there.
And let's say
or not payload
or
not payload
dot value. So at least some housekeeping, right?
We should not trust what arbitrary clients send
to our rest APIs.
And I hope that's somewhat,
you
know,
aligning with that.
So, but if everything works great, we wanna
return a new response and we simply say,
no, because we didn't wanna set something there
and we set two zero one or maybe
we set another header,
headers.
That's
the location header over there and we set
that to API,
what was it?
Values,
Values
at position
key.
And I'm messing up this one because
status.
That's correct.
This is that one. This is that one.
Okay. What's going on there?
Return new response.
I don't provide a body
and then I why is it green? It
looks weird.
Expression is not capable. Status,
I had there's
status
two zero one. Did I did I make
a typo? No.
Headers is an object. Object
gets if I do that.
Is Permanent location doesn't need wrapped in quotes.
Yeah.
No. I think it's not it doesn't want
backticks there.
That's weird.
Doesn't need anything, right? Like it's just the
location. Yeah,
you're right. You're right. It could be just
like that. Yeah.
Good call.
Yeah, that's good.
All right. So this would basically be a
simple CRUD API backed by
key value store.
Let's try it. Let's go there
and do a spin
up dash dash build.
So you also can, you know, save that
spin build command and run both in one.
And we should end up with, again, an
API running on 3,000.
Okay.
Let's
take this one.
Oh, no, let's go away.
Yeah.
Let's take this one
and do a curl I x get
values
and we expect an empty array. Okay, so
let's
do ix
post
and post in
content
type
application
JSON
and data being
value
value.
Hello.
And there is a
double quote missing.
Push post that to that end. Oh, 404.
You need a key in the URL, so
values slash. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Foo.
That was a good one.
Oh.
Destructed parameter is undefined. Oh. I think you
used dot values in the code instead of
value.
No. I think this is this is my
mistake.
And you said values and I used?
Yeah. Oh, no. But and your post handler.
Yeah.
In the post handler.
Handle set
over there.
Yeah.
Oh, no. You just passed the whole payload.
Okay. Never mind. Yeah. Okay. Let me let
me try.
Yeah. I think I messed up the parameter
thing.
No. I was I was looking at the
wrong I was looking at this one.
So async,
we get a request
and then it's using destruction over there.
And it'll set and then we grab the
key.
That's weird.
Let me try what happens if I curl
the get endpoint
at foo.
That works. Okay.
So if I don't do that,
what is it? Is it is it
It's a request.
Come on that.
That's
that looks wrong to me.
That looks wrong to me.
Ah, come on. It's it's telling me what
to do. Right? So I wanna get the
request. So if I then
args
and I'm expecting it exactly
this way,
it looks correct.
Let me try. Let me try once again.
Yeah. I think it's me messing up right
now the
syntax of the ET router.
I'm posting
some value
to API values for error.
Destructured
parameter is undefined.
So this has to happen over there.
Let's
call in extras
and let's pass in extras. Let's do the
JavaScript
trick over here. Extras is
any
and let's say console. Log
json
oops. This one, and then let's do json's
stringify
extras.
Sometimes you just got to do it.
It's just
I'm not seeing it right now and I
think this is the easiest way to get
some hint on what I hold wrong.
Okay.
So obviously Oh, now we get a bad
request. Okay.
And undefined.
That's interesting.
We are
so okay. Let me pull well,
that's not me pulling.
Let's look at enterprise.
So I created a repository with like common
patterns and how to implement them in spin
with different languages.
And there is an http crud and I
just have to look up
this syntax.
Oh, it's the other way around. You see?
Okay.
That's
a pity. Okay. I have to memorize that.
Maybe it's too late today,
but let's fix that and get our app
in a in a working state.
It is seven almost 07:30PM
for you. Right? I mean, it's
been okay.
Yeah. Good call. So I'm I'm hurry hurrying
up right now.
I'm trying to find the right Versus Code
instance right now. This is it. Okay.
So it's the other way around. Sorry for
that. It's key. Yeah. It worked in the
get handler. So obviously, it's the other way
around. Right?
Explaining the error
makes it so obvious to see it works
here. So it had to be the other
way around.
Okay. So we can remove our little helper
over here again
and
say this is key
and we expect that to be a string.
So now we should be back to a
valid TypeScript.
Yep.
Let's go there, cycle through the workflow once
again.
So app is running
and let's look for the post request.
Now request is undefined.
This
is super weird. What's happening over here? Post
item.
It
looks
It looks pretty much the same, doesn't it?
Yeah.
Yep.
I'm
prepared.
Let me check.
Let me open this one.
Oh, I'm not pulling,
I'm not pulling things over there.
Okay. I don't see the error for the
CRUD right now.
Maybe given the the time and given how
how long we are already in the stream.
But but give me a sec. Key is
set. Request is not set. And it's complaining
about that
API post. So there is a fundamental error
somewhere.
I don't see it.
I don't see it. Hover over the dot
post, does it give us the signature for
the handler?
Oh, yeah. It's a request handler. I request
that takes an array.
Oh, no. Can I can I simply pull
it by over here?
So that's a re any
yeah. It could
handlers.
Okay. Request any.
I did that like a trillion times.
I'm not seeing it. Let me check.
Post items like this. Params.
Oh, yeah. It's here. It's not key. It's
not immediately. It's like this. It's params.
Maybe it's like that.
But that's weird. That means this should could
also not work.
Let
me try.
Let me try one more time. If not,
we move on.
Spin
up build.
And there we are.
So curling
the get endpoint
gives me a not found. Oh, let's do
Yeah.
Let's try the post endpoint over there.
Request is undefined.
That's so weird.
Am I posting to API values? Yeah. That's
correct.
I was super confident this being the the
signature.
Like that.
I have to try that once more because
that was almost almost what I had in
the first place.
Besides,
yeah, parameters. I I bet that's working right
now because parameters make sense. Otherwise, my key
could infer whatever's in that extras object.
Let me try.
So
Oh, come on.
That's super weird.
Now it's happy again with that but not
happy with my params.
I better had it working like a day.
Oh, let me check.
So
where am I? In my demos folder. Let
me check.
My IP, it's CDKV.
This is CDKV
two.
All Rust samples.
This looks pretty close to what we had,
right?
Besides that the parameter over here is called
ID instead of key.
Okay.
So I'm pretty confident that's exactly what we
had.
But I love to be proven wrong and
this thread not working.
How how to address that would basically e
d e d router
basically look at getting star
registering routes over there and they are pulling
this.
That's correct.
And
it's just a question of pulling
not just the parameter,
also complete example
pulling the
request in.
But I had that. I think that's exactly
the same as we had over there.
Yeah.
Oh,
Maybe we have to tell.
Maybe we have to tell, hey, you should
use the request.
Yeah. That's right.
Router fetch request
or router handler. Yeah.
I'm pretty confident that should be the right
So it looks like you just passed the
request,
and then we used request dot text to
get the array buffer.
So if you just get
Let me yeah. Okay.
But
let's So there's no function because there's no
request dot array buffer. It's request
dot text
according to one of the examples I found
online.
Mhmm. But I I don't know if that's
correct. Okay.
Let's do one thing to double check that.
So if we lock the key for the
get
and for, I think, the post action that
basically it it it throws over here already
in
that function that I'm calling.
Right? So if I do that and if
I do a console log
request,
so like this, and I guess it makes
sense to JSON stringify both,
and to see what's on the object.
Stringify.
Okay. So,
there.
F1.
Okay. So it's running. So let's do a
curl
to
this one. So we get a not found
and we expect now full being locked to
the terminal. Okay.
Meaning
this works,
pulling the key like that.
Okay. Next is calling the post endpoint and
we expect the key to be locked first
and the request to be locked second. Okay.
Curling the post endpoint, we get that error
and we see foo. Great.
Okay. So foo, it could either be
that
this is key.
You know, it could also be the case
that, right, not a second argument was logging
and the request
request being
this.
So let's just for before you run this
again to save as a step oh, I'm
sorry. I guess, why not change key to
params and just dump out the whole first
object as well? The the whole
This one? Yeah. Yeah. It makes sense.
Params
params
and
dump params,
and pass in params.
Let's
pretend there is a key. Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, that's smarter.
All right, and let's curl it again. Oh,
cyclic object.
Is now undefined.
Params undefined.
So this was correct. This was key. If
we go back to key
But how can it be undefined and resolved
to key?
No, that was just key
being that string.
Okay. Let's try again.
I don't see how that could work.
Yeah. You're oh, because yeah.
It's an array. Right?
And I'm destructuring
now.
Is your quest and key just in the
same
object? Oh, you mean like this?
Yeah. Like this. Yeah.
Is it that simple?
Is it that simple? Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Let's Did you build it? Alright. Yeah.
Have to clear that.
Destruction
parameters
on defined.
Okay. So it should be up and running.
It is. Let's try.
ArrayBufferRequest
is undefined.
That's super weird.
All right. Maybe we just skip the post
stuff and then Yeah. Yeah. Maybe it's worth
pulling like the working example there.
Right? Which is leading to, okay, there is
a post endpoint
like
personalize over here
that's using like a popular
NPM
module from the community
which is lang change js. So the idea
of this example
is to basically give us a front end
where
we can enter
like personal information
about the potential customer
and like a general product description and then
leverage a large language model
to come up with a personal product
description to make that super
engaging and the customer automatically wants to buy
that product. That's the idea.
As you can see, we use the router
and
we pull
the request array buffer that's get turned
into a JSON object that you know, matches
like my
interface over there. So again, we have the
product description,
we have some
fundamental
information about the customer, first name, last name,
age, gender, nationality,
and recent purchases.
Yeah. And then after checking everything,
we load some configuration data. So this is
basically,
you know, adding like
spin variables
to like what we use from spin.
And then we use OLAMA
as a as a large language model, you
know, through its lang chain package,
computer prompt
and basically
use chaining to say, hey, dear large language
model come up with a personalized
with a personalized
product description
whatever, for whatever I entered into the form.
And it's following the same pattern, right? So
I have an API
and I have a front end. However, in
that case, there's little more in the
index HTML.
There's also
like a minified version of Bootstrap
and some super simple
JavaScript because all I do from the front
end side is issuing a fetch call
to my post endpoint exposed
through the Spin app.
All right.
I think the interesting thing, interesting pieces
besides, okay, adding lang chain
using Olama,
the Olama LLM
are in SpinTML.
So we configure
three application variables.
Hey, where's my OLAMA service? OLAMA is open
source server that can run different large language
models.
So where's that API?
Which model do you wanna use? Because OLAMA
can run different things. LAMA,
LAMA free, Mistral,
DeepSeq,
whatever, right?
And what temperature?
So how how let's say
how creative
could the large language model become in generating
a response according to my question.
So
the there are three variables
and we use them to, for example, allow
the API
to do outbound HTTP
to our OLAMA server.
So we have to explicitly whitelist that.
But we also wanna tell the API to
make the the app itself, the API configurable
without us having to recompile again and again
if things change.
So we allow the very the
API component
to use the variables ola mappaseurl
model temperature.
In
contrast,
the front end neither
has to do outbound HTTP
because the API is served on the same
origin
nor
does it have to know about
the OLAMA
API
which model we wanna use.
This is just information that is only accessible
to the API component. So no matter what
the front end component does,
it is not
able to access those values. So I can
find granular pin
or
assign values to components. And I think that's
the most interesting part over here.
Okay, so how to assign them? So the
easiest way is you could specify environment variables
with a prefix
spin underscore variable
and then those are picked up. But you
can also load environment variables from things like
HashiCorp Vault for example,
or when deploying to Fermion Cloud, you can
specify those variables
during deployment time and they are securely stored
encrypted at rest in Fermion Cloud.
In
SpinCube,
you could pull them from Kubernetes config maps,
from Kubernetes secrets,
so all the familiar places, right,
are supported.
Okay.
So now,
I'm,
mentally
doing
crossing
all the fingers that I have that this
works.
And I'm super confident it works but I
don't know why the previous demo did not
work. So I do a spin build, right,
to compile everything.
And let me cancel this one because I
wanna run the app on the same port.
Okay.
So I can
either go down the road and can say
spin
variable and specify it like that,
or I can
inline
specify the variables and I pre like
wrote that one.
So let me
I hope my terminal my terminal does not
support new line over there. So what I'm
basically doing and I'm saying, hey, there's a
spin variable called ollama
base URL. Set
their its value to this URL.
And there is a value
a variable called oLamaModel
set that to DeepSeek r one latest.
Cycling back to the spin TOML,
so those are required.
So the app won't start without me specifying
them.
For temperature,
I defined a default value of o dot
four. So I could override it, but I
don't have to specify it because there is
already a value.
Okay.
So now let me execute that.
Now click the link. This is my
super
like fancy,
let's call it fancy
UI over there.
As I told you, I'm not a I'm
not a
UX
CSS guy.
So let me do first
name, last name,
male,
age. Yes, I'm
42 years old, German.
I recently bought like the super awesome
hiking
shoe. Oh, hiking, sorry. Hiking shoe
44 whatever.
I bought a new iPhone
Pro
and the product description. Let's say we have
the
Nebulus
Smart
Speaker
3,000.
Or let's say the no.
Is Bluetooth
water
resistant
smart
speaker.
So, okay, let's say this is our product
description. And right now I have the Olama.
The Olama
server is running on Linode. So I created
like
a small Linode, deployed OLAMA according to their
guide, deployed DeepSeq.
And right now, it's not
it's not pre warmed, meaning this will take
a couple of seconds.
It's basically right now constructing
prompt,
calling into the OLAMA server.
And then it's just waiting for the LLM
to finish reasoning and giving us like a
super awesome
like product description
for the Nebulus Smart Speaker 3,000.
The thing
that I like about DeepSig is
how they expose the reasoning. You know, deepsake,
you know, there's a lot of discussions about
it. I don't wanna go down that road.
It's more like
it makes me it makes it so
easy to understand how the AI comes to
this
product description. Right? I'm a 42 year old
German guy who recently bought an iPhone Pro
and some hiking shoes.
So he's into tech, but also active outdoors.
Right? So and and, you know, reading through
that reasoning gives me also hints on how
I could improve my product engineering or how
I could tailor it even more into
a certain or particular direction.
But I
don't wanna go down that deep into AI.
I think the
super
interesting
thing why I've chosen this example is
a,
SpinApps are configurable from the outside.
B, if you don't mess up the syntax
of the router, like I did,
you can
with these create like Rust
TRUD APIs
and you can bring in like what's ever,
you know, out there in the ecosystem
and
use it. So in case of JavaScript,
I right now choose
langchain the core framework and langchain the OLAMA
LLM
configuration
classes
and functions they expose.
They wanna have a abort controller that's not
in the Starling run monkey runtime. So I
looked what's the most popular
polyfill for the airport controller in fetch
and added that. Right. And my app does
not look different from any other TypeScript app.
Right? Besides,
I mean, this one is not using the
Spin SDK. So it's one to one looking
like a regular TypeScript application. I can roll
my own TypeScript files, modules, bring them in
and use them as they are
and have configuration
values to make my app work in different
environments without having to change the code.
Yeah,
so that's basically the third example. And looking
at that, I'm still super angry.
And I don't see it. I don't see
it.
Let's don't worry about it. It's it's too
late for you. I don't want
Yeah. It is.
Be back over here.
So I'm gonna just recap that before we
finish up.
If anyone in the audience does have any
questions, you've got about one minute to drop
them in there, we'll do our best to
answer them before we we'll outsource and go
get these dinner. So Spend is an open
source project. It is now a CNCF sandbox
project.
It is a WebAssembly server side WebAssembly framework
that allows you to write applications
and HTTP endpoints and a whole bunch of
other stuff.
It focuses on a strong developer experience. As
we've seen, we could do spend new to
get an empty project, which give us, an
environment where we can add as many polyglot
components as we want. We can add Rust.
We can add Go. We could add Python,
and we've already seen that we can add
TypeScript.
These can be path based routing based on
HTTP with the ability to pull in any
of the packages from the language runtime. We
saw
Thorsten pulling in lang chain, a very popular
package
right now within the NPM node, etcetera worlds.
We've seen OpenTelemetry integration. We've seen OCI push
and pull.
And we've seen even the ability to use
CRDs and deploy WebAssembly applications on top of
Kubernetes.
And all of that in one hour and
forty two minutes. Bravo, Sorsen. That was a
a fantastic,
fantastic demo.
Yeah. Thanks once again for having me. Sorry
again for me messing up the second,
demo, but still I think
I think it's super ex we are in
a super exciting time, especially to, you know,
with all the movements in
the spin ecosystems,
been going to CNCF and WebAssembly
as a general tech evolving that that
quickly. Super exciting.
So thanks again for hosting this, David. And
yep.
Awesome. And thank you for, again, doing back
to back streams, taking time out of your
day, and, we hope that people that watch
this enjoy it. Please remember to give us
a thumbs up. There will be links in
the description afterwards to the examples repository, the
spin repository, and Thorsten's socials.
So
I think that's us for the day. And
thank you, Indigo. I appreciate the presentation and
the perseverance. I love a bit of live
debugging, and I hope that wasn't too stressful
for Thorsten.
So, yeah,
I'm gonna let you go. I'm not gonna
say anything else. I'm just gonna say thank
you. I hope to see you at KubeCon
in a couple of weeks. If anyone has
at KubeCon, make sure to pop by the
Project Pavilion where I assume Spend may or
may not have a booth, but I assume
will
either way. So let's go say hello.
Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Well, have a great day. Have a
good evening. Have a good week. I'll see
you all next time. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Bye bye.